da ist ein weg
[Musik]
das system wurde sehr genau durchgeplant
die bestellungen müssen schnell und
effizient laufen dafür brauchen wir eine
stabile app und zusätzliche
arbeitskräfte
eventuell müssen wir die küche auch
vergrössern richtig der lieferservice
muss von anfang an perfekt funktionieren
sonst bestellt niemand zweimal
ich stimme zu das ist gut
haben sie sonst noch fragen erst einmal
nicht und was sagen sie
ich denke darüber nach ich melde mich in
den nächsten tagen wieder bei das war es
ja jetzt müssen wir warten
ich glaube das nicht korrekt leider
geraten wer möchte etwas trinken
[Musik]
entschuldigung ich nico was machst du
hier wissen deine eltern muss die hip
ist selber ich muss dir persönlich sagen
was was musste mir persönlich sagen wir
können uns nicht mehr sehen nico es tut
mir leid ich mag dich
[Musik]